days out from the release of the comic
book anti-hero movie venom
several news outlets have obtained some
juicy bits of info about the movie's two
post credits scenes
as well as one big reveal that would tie
into a potential sequel
so what does the tom hardy starring
ruben fleischer directed movie have in
store for viewers
grab a snack and check it out
[Music]
now for those of you who want to walk
into venom knowing just the basics about
what will go down
we advise you to avert your eyes if
these reports of the post-credits scenes
turn out to be the real deal
then they're set up to spoil not just
what will happen but also what
definitely
won't happen during the movie one more
time for anyone not paying attention
major spoilers ahead according to a
report from mcu cosmic the first
venom post-credits scene will see
hardy's eddie brock miraculously
maintaining his job as a journalist
even after transforming into the people
eating fang-toothed venom
eddie hungry to chase down new leads and
cover a fresh story after his wild
investigation of the life foundation
reportedly travels to san quentin prison
to interview a very special inmate
cletus cassidy the serial killer better
known in marvel comics as
carnage cassidy as has long been rumored
will in fact be played by woody
harrelson with his involvement in the
movie having been intended as a secret
harrelson will reportedly sport a
comic's accurate red-headed look by
donning a ginger wig
lurking in police custody as a looming
menace when approached by eddie brock
cletus asks if he quote
wants to hear the carnage of the murders
he's committed
you heard right that's a grade a
by the comic books tease for a sequel if
we've ever seen one
so if venom does even halfway decently
at the box office it looks like a
follow-up should be coming in hot
the possibility of harrelson's
involvement as carnage has been
circulating for months
after plenty of speculation and
uncertainty harrelson finally broke his
silence by confirming his involvement in
the movie
as well as an untitled sequel speaking
to collider in may 2018 harrelson said
i'm in a little fraction of this movie
but i'll be in the next one you know
prior to harrelson's remarks there was
speculation that carnage
a well-known adversary of both venom and
spider-man would be the main villain of
the movie
but that hashtag show published reports
claiming that cassidy would mostly
appear in the post-credits tease
claims which these new reports seem to
confirm the outlet cited an unnamed
source saying that cassidy would be in
the custody of ravencroft institute
founder dr
ashley kafka a marvel comics character
who is highly experienced in treating
criminally insane
super people that source also relayed
that during eddie's talk with cassidy
a part of the venom symbiote starts
lurching toward him before the screen
cuts to black
this suggests that somewhere between the
first and second venom movies cassidy
will obtain a symbiote of his
own thus becoming the villain known as
carnage if true
this would align with the marvel comics
lore in which cassidy transforms into
the beastly entity after a prison
breakout
as for the second post-credits scene it
reportedly opens with a scrawl of text
reading meanwhile in another
spider-verse it then launches into a
sneak peek at sony's upcoming animated
feature spider-man
into the spider-verse which centers on
miles morales gwen stacy
and older peter parker and more
alternate universe spider people
this scene should arguably be less
exciting than the first one since it
isn't directly related to venom but it
should nonetheless put a smile on the
faces of spider fans
still it's hard not to be a little
disappointed post credit scenes are all
basically just ads for upcoming movies
but this sounds like it's literally
just an advertisement for another sony
flick and we can't imagine that will
thrill too many people after sitting
through 10 minutes of credits
but hey at least the movie looks pretty
great
so now that we probably know what the
venom post credits scene will entail
when during those credits can viewers
expect to see them according to
mcu cosmic the first scene is a more
traditional mid-credit scene that will
start not too long after the movie
itself ends
the second spider-verse tease is
reportedly at the very end of the
credits
serving as a little bonus for the people
who've stuck around screenrant however
is reporting it a little differently
they say the additional bits of footage
will actually play out back to back
until the movie comes out it's hard to
say for certain but it sounds like these
two scenes are the only scenes to watch
out for
of course at this point almost two
decades into superhero mania many
audiences are conditioned not to go
anywhere until the staff is sweeping the
theater
last minute surprises are still possible
so that's the only way to be 100
sure you saw everything but as of now
it's almost certain
carnage is coming eventually